the Dark Tower stars Idris Elba as
Roland the gunslinger and Matthew
McConaughey as the man in black and is
the story of a young boy named Jake
played by the young actor Tom Taylor who
has dreams and visions of another world
in which there's a war going on and a
dark tower that holds the universe
together and when Jake discovers a
portal to this world and he runs into
the gunslinger himself he starts on an
adventure to try to destroy the man in
black because Roland is on a revenge
path leading straight to him this movie
is based off of the epic series of
Stephen King books and quite a bit of
them have been mashed into this movie
it's not really any one book it's an
amalgamation of many of them and to some
fans dismay in fact this one sitting
here as well I'm not huge on this movie
but I won't lie there's quite a bit of
fun to be had with The Dark Tower I
think that there are two different types
of people who are going to watch this
movie there's going to be the person who
comes in and like yeah notice bond I
enjoyed that movie who's never read the
books in their life and this is going to
be the people who are hardcore followers
of those books who watch that and go
what did I just watch that was nothing
like the books but ourselves was good
and that's what we're going to run into
problems whenever you adapt anything
whether it's a book an anime a TV show
foreign film into a movie here they're
going to have problems there's going to
be expectations and a lot of fans are
going to be disappointed with how short
this movie is it's like 95 minutes it's
a very quick movie it's not like it's
trying to adapt the first book or the
second it's got a lot of pieces of all
of them but I am NOT super well versed
in this book series full disclosure I
have not read all of them King is my
favorite author and I love his novels
but I haven't read every single dark
tower book a friend of mine however has
who saw this movie with me tonight and
afterwards I said so how faithful was it
to the whole series and he went oh god I
don't know what I just saw
so people are going to be mad about this
movie I guarantee it
I however found it to be fine it's
unfortunately a little conventional
Idris Elba is great as Roland he has a
lot hidden behind his eyes he as usual
as one of the best parts of this movie
one of the standouts for me was the
young actor Tom Taylor I thought he had
a lot of range he went from being very
reserved to being very angry to having
some really emotional scenes and he's
also got a lot of humor
there's a lot of fish out of the water
stuff when he first arrived in this
other world where he meets the
gunslinger he has to get used to the way
things are there and then later in the
film Roland deals with something very
similar on our version of Earth it was
kind of like Wonder Woman walking around
going like Oh baby oh I'm going to carry
my sword and shield everywhere and crisp
I'm like no no you can't do that
like the young actor in the film Tom
Taylor the character Jake he's kind of
the Chris Pine of the situation he has
to be like no no you can't say those
things and it actually provided quite a
bit of great comedy the action sequences
are pretty good there's a lot of really
nice stunt work some of the special
effects are fine
it's nothing mind-blowing Matthew
McConaughey is the man in black was
something I was very worried about but I
found him fine in the movie like this is
kind of the word I keep going back to
it's fine it's perfectly serviceable
unfortunately some fans are going to
want a lot more than that I didn't go to
this one with mammoth expectations in
fact I thought it looked really bad from
the trailers and so the fact that I left
being like that was a conventional movie
but it entertained me for 90 minutes is
more than I expected going in if I were
to hone all my problems down into just
one thing this movie feels rushed it is
very short there's a lot they go over
there are some scenes of exposition that
go by very quickly and by the end of the
film my friends and I were talking and
we realized we didn't really learn that
much about this world it does kind of
rely on you having some knowledge of the
books because the way they present
certain things like the villains in this
movie it's very surface level you don't
really get behind them and learn all
that much about them the characters
particularly Jake
fairly fleshed out roland has some nice
development as well but the man in black
he's just a really evil sorceror guy and
there isn't that much to him Matthew
McConaughey clearly is relishing the
role in having a lot of fun with it
but it's all as I said kind of surface
level which was disappointing there's a
lot of references to other Stephen King
books in this movie which some might
find annoying but it didn't bother me I
actually kind of enjoyed it there's a
Rita Hayworth poster in a gun shop one
of the portal numbers they have to
remember is 1408 they refer to psychic
activity as shine or shining I don't
know I kind of enjoyed it it made it
feel like it was a Stephen King universe
or something most critics and fans are
probably going to be disappointed with
this movie which I can understand I
certainly don't love it it has a lot of
problems Sony has taken this and made it
a franchise piece there's definitely an
attempt at building here and I think
that was a mistake
I think they should have just tried to
make a great film which should really be
every filmmakers goal but today we live
in a franchise driven world and it's
clear that that's what they're trying to
do still the performances and the action
sequences and the heart of the
relationship between Roland and Jake
which I found touching are some
positives in a kind of conventional
movie unfortunately I'm going to give
the Dark Tower of C+ guys thank you very
much as always for watching stay tuned
for more Stephen King reviews coming to
you very soon leading up to it you guys
are the best and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]